[音楽]
むーん
僕はの小さい頃ですね
映画スターウォーズが大好きだったんですがその理由は
映画スター簿というのは
高い才能を持つことよりもその最後の使い方を高い次元で理解することその方が人生に
とっては重要だということを伝えてくれているからだと思っています映画スター
ウォーズの中には
ダースベイダーと言われるキャラクターが出てきます彼は
県最中の天才でした
世の中を変えると思われていただけど
自らの根底に流れる愛の存在に気づけず
ダークサイドに堕ちてしまった
一方でその息子であるルークス解剖かというのは彼よりは才能がなかったんだけど自分
のサイドの使い方を
ただし繰り返していたため最終的にダースベイダーを倒すことができた
つまりこの映画というのは実は
高い才能を持つことよりもその採用の使い方を高い次元で理解していることをその方が
私たちの人生にとって
もっとプラスになるとそういうことを伝えてくれているなと
僕は認識していますそしてその差を開けたのは自分の金でん中に流れる
愛情や深い感情に気づけるかどうかだと
6があるとき人間には3つの才能があるのではないかという仮説を持ちました
そしてそれを本にしましたそしてそれはベストセラーになりました
その3つというのは一つは創造性
独創的で見たこともないプロセスで物事を進める才能
2つは
再現性
論理的で堅実なプロセスで物事を進める際の
3つは今日完成
人の気持ちや感情に配慮しながら
もらおうと進める際の皆さんはこの3つの知恵
どれが自分の才能として強いと思われますか
だけど僕が思うのは
自分が何の才能を持っているかよりもはるかにもっと重要なのはその才能を何のために
使うのか
それだと今僕は隔週しています
そしてその実はきっかけとなるのは
愛情あるいは深い感情に自らの根底に流れるその気持ちに気づくことだというふうに
確信しています
僕は小さい頃
体が弱くて
喘息でそしてアトピーもありましただから学校に行きたくても行けない日もありました
悔しい思いもたくさんしましただけどその時でも振り返ってみると自分の父親や
あるいは母親家族は無償の愛で自分をサポートしてくれてそして育ってくれた
だから今
になって思うのはその彼らにその桜を返すのは前提でそれよりも少しだけ大きなはで
返すことそれが自分の才能の使い方であるというふうに確信していますそしてそのどれ
だけ大きなはで返せるのかどうか
それが自分の才能の大きさによって規定されている
高
いう構造だというふうに認識していますつまり重要なのは
自分の才能を正しく理解するということは自分の根底の中に流れている
愛情や深い感情に気づくことそれがいつもスタートだということです
皆さんも不思議に思ったことはないですよ
なぜアーティストやミュージシャンというのは
歳をとればとるほど年齢を重ねれば重ねるほどいきなり世界平和や愛について歌いだす
か生きられるたいですますよね
僕もすぐちっちゃい頃は不思議で仕方ありませんでした
だけど今になって理解したのはそれはそのタイミング
その年齢がそのアーティストミュージシャンが自分の根底の中にこんな感情があったん
だと確信を持ったタイミングだとそういうことだというふうに認識しています
ています
人は
死を意識すると
自分の人生観や考え方が変わるというふうに言われています
僕は実はそれは
愛の作用愛に帰すことの作用と同じだというふうに今は認識しています
そしてそれはタイミングは人によって遅かったり早かったりもする
遅い人は死ぬ前日まで世の中を憎み
としてねために主前日までその感情があることに気づかない
だけど早い人は10代や20代で気づくかもしれない
またある人は自分の身近な人の死によって気づき自分にこんな感情があったんだなと
気づくかもしれない
またある人は初めて自分の子供を見てその顔を見た時に自分の中にもこんな感情があっ
たんだなと
に気づくことがかもしれないつまり大事なのは
自分の中に流れているその根底に流れている
愛情に5何歳で気づくのかだと
そして
先ほどしてと同じと言いましたが
しも同じですなぜ集を意識すると人の生き方わかるのかそれは自分の人生というのが
絶対的なものではなくて言う
相対的なものであるというふうに傷からですつまり
そして愛そして才能というのは実が三位一体ですごく身近なものなのです
近くにあるものです
しに来ずことを愛に気付くことそれはほぼニアリーイコールで自分の最後の使い方を
築くこと
自分のミッションに気づくことだと僕は確信しています今日は実はこれで終わろうかな
と思ったんですが
せっかくですねあの頭に帰ってきたのでじゃあ具体的に僕が船んですね意識してる
才能というか能力の使い方みたいなの3つほどご紹介できればなというふうに思ってい
ます
創造性の最もとうとうい才能の使い方というのは人とは違った形の人間のあり方を認め
描くこと
僕はそう思ってます作家の役割本素敵な役割というのは人とは違った形の愛を描き
そしてそれを丁寧に見せていくことです皆は8いうけれど
だけどその a のそばにある a rush や b というあり方があってもいい
んじゃないかと
それを描くことです
だからもしも今日僕たちにできることがあるとすれば
家に帰って30秒81分でもいいので自分とは違うなとか自分とは全然考え方は違うな
という人のためにその時間を使ってあげることだと思っています
二つ目再現性再現性の最もとうとう使い方のひとつというのは背景を伝えることです
世の中にあふれている映画やドラマというのは実は結論全部一緒です
全部署全部愛は大事な愛は大事な愛は台座
希望は大事な希望は第二は今日は大事だよ曲考えてみた全部一緒ですだけどサッカー
それを物語という技術を使って丁寧に丁寧に描いてくるそして物語をつく
というのは本当にとてつもなく大変な作業です
だからそう対象に対して愛がなければ
描くことができません
つまりもしも今日僕たちができることがあるとすれば
家に帰って例えば勉強しろとか
a 白 b しろその結論だけを言うのではなくてその背景にある
なぜそれが大事なのかなぜそれがあなたの実にとって
重要なものであるのかというのをその物語を描くことです
これが二つ目です
3つ目共感性の最も尊いいいさ色の使い方というのは実は僕はごきげんであることだと
思っています
人はええ偉くなればなるほどリーダーになればなるほど親になればなるほど実はご
きげんであることが最も尊い才能の使い方だと確信しています
動画普段 it 企業の経営者としても働いていますが皆さんも想像してほしいんです
が
会社の上司やリーダーが吹き件
あったり怒ってたりしたらそれだけで才能が萎れてしまいますよね
あるいはもっというのであれば思い出してほしいです皆さんが小学生や幼稚園生だった
とき家に帰ってお父さんやお母さんがイライラしたり不機嫌だったらそれだけで心が旬
ってなりましたよね
つまり人は
偉くなればなるほどリーダーになればなるほど実はご機嫌になることが最もとうとうし
才能のひと使い方のひとつだと僕は確信しています
冒頭に戻ります映画スターウォーズは6たちにこう問い掛けていました
高い才能を持つことよりもその最後の使い方を高い次元で理解することの方がはるかに
重要ではないですかと
今日の話が皆さんにとって何かのフックになればとても幸いですありがとうございまし
た
[拍手]